gratitude i mean i hate the word hack
like oh it's a dopamine hack or it's a
serotonin i i don't like the word hack
because hey it's disrespectful to
hackers who do a real thing
yeah and b a hack implies that it's
some sort of trick that you're you're
you're kind of gaming the system
you know what what works is mechanism
right biological mechanisms
were designed to work and they were
selected for
to work under variable conditions and as
you know and i know and
we have great appreciation for the fact
that the nervous system was designed to
be an adaptive machine
so that you don't have to sleep eight
hours every night
you can do this thing and things like
gratitude
allow you to tap into chemical resources
and that's not a hack the fact that
being grateful for something external to
the event
happens to release serotonin and have a
certain soothing effect or
dopamine and give you more epinephrine
and let you go further
that's not a hack that's actually what
allowed the human machine
to evolve to the point that it is now
every time
you know an inventor eventually created
something that worked and felt great
about it you can imagine that the
the first you know air flight felt
pretty awesome
and motivated those people to go on and
do more they they didn't just go huh you
know yawn and go have a beer
so being able to access the genuine in
internal states of gratitude and reward
works
you can't trick the system you can't
pretend that you're grateful for
something but if you can identify or
attach yourself to some larger
goal or something that's deeply
gratifying to you or place it in service
to
a relative that passed away that you
care a lot about
that's not a hack that's accessing the
deepest components of your nervous
system and um to steal your kind of
lingo you know there's real beauty there
right